need to start treating your guests with
respect okay
i mean look at her she's a shining
example like just nothing but kindness i
come in
an amazing hug you know and
yeah i'm gonna have a long time
literally i'm gonna have a long
conversation with ethan tonight look
should we call him leave ethan out of
this ethan's not gonna answer we'll see
yeah let's see what is i'll call him
please don't call him yeah i'm gonna
call him i [ __ ] hate ethan i know you
do
please don't do this to me give me this
over here
did you whisper bro
you have his number but he does
you know it by heart i just didn't save
it that's crazy yeah i forget to save it
just you you only have um ela's number
really yeah
well i'll say this hello's very badass
she's way cooler than anything called
hila told her to put
yeah
she's not gonna answer she's busy she's
running a fortune five you're texting
today texting today i highly doubt that
look at this guy's trying to flex yeah
yeah i don't believe it okay we'll see
ethan hold on hold on speaker first
ethan
yes it's bobby lee he answered i know
all right so
i have this [ __ ] face oliver trees go
[ __ ] yourself i love you freeze on my
podcast he's being a real [ __ ]
are you guys alive right now yeah
not like why didn't you ask me before
you invite him on your show i would have
told you not to do it
[ __ ] you eat this so it was so difficult
he wouldn't say hey
you're a [ __ ] punk ass [ __ ] this
guy's a dude i swear to god his music
sucks i know
three billion streams how's that suck on
that big boy let me talk to bobby
yeah i should have called you before
because this has been a nightmare
how long have you been doing it over an
hour it's like he won't say anything i
go what he would say i'm far strong i'm
forming religion i go tell me about the
religion he goes i am not allowed to
talk about it
he's just [ __ ] he just lies he's
like a pathological liar that's not true
seriously and then like he as soon as i
opened the door he wanted a hog i'm like
who [ __ ] does that
what's he what's he got like his fake
ass mullet with the extension shot
yeah [ __ ] you ethan he had to go to the
dressing room he had to go to my room
and go i have to change
he has hair plugs by the way shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] hilarious man you're
[ __ ] punk it's all plugs it's all
plugs right
yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up you know i
called him a uh
what i call him a fancy turtle he looks
like a fancy turtle and he got all got
hurt i know
i know right yes
[ __ ] yeah you know what i also said i
said that he looks like he has progeria
without having progeria
that's so true it's so true right
it's like it's that it's that one
disease where you you
you look really old as a little kid
oh he's like benjamin but yeah like but
yeah in river yeah when he first yeah
was born yeah
you know what's crazy his career is like
benjamin button he had one hit with life
goes on and on and on and then every new
song gets less views geez that's amazing
thank you so much give me that ethan
[ __ ] you
you're a [ __ ] so much for giving me
that information ethan let me talk to
him no no you're talking to him now he
[ __ ] i want to talk to him because
you've been rude ever since i've been
asking you questions this whole time you
won't give me any [ __ ] information
you've been a [ __ ] [ __ ] too i have
not been you you made me my enemy
and don't make me myself for the enemy
all right that's what you do you know
there's a special place in hell for
people like you and ethan klein yeah
what what
it's called heaven
how much are you paying these [ __ ]
guys laughing
ass jokes all right so next time i'm
about to [ __ ] walk right now you're
not walking dude i'm walking you're
finishing this thing and we're not
paying you go [ __ ] he asked for money
[ __ ] off ethan tell your accountant to
wire the [ __ ] money i'm done playing
games
this [ __ ] guy owes me for the last
three [ __ ] episodes he told me he was
gonna pay me once in person as i did the
next one he keeps dangling the [ __ ]
carrot i never said i was gonna pay you
anything that's [ __ ] [ __ ] we
agreed on a
55-45 split in my favor
and now you're getting to me through
bobby
look your tongue's moving
[Laughter]
i think he's getting turned on right now
you know what ethan you're turning me on
right now
he's been turned on the whole [ __ ]
time
i [ __ ] up the second i walked into the
[ __ ] house dude
shut up oliver
all right so here's the deal dude i
think i [ __ ] up this either because i
came in real serious and trying to be
right but i think what i should have
done up front has been hostile
oh well you kind of he doesn't give you
any choice he's like he's like the
biggest [ __ ] i've ever yeah he's been
shut the [ __ ] up dude drove me into this
yeah remember the gatsby that you
crashed when you did an interview a
while ago on a show yeah yeah
so he took the gatsby and he [ __ ] hit
me with it yep i did do that
and that was the greatest moment of my
[ __ ] life on our property yeah you're
banned from the property i don't give a
[ __ ]
i'll show up whenever i want no you
can't and
hey buster i'm about to leak the address
of your shitty little location anyways
oh look at him look at him so next time
you [ __ ] pawn me off one of your
[ __ ] lose-lose all right just warn me
before you should be so [ __ ] lucky to
have me here
do you know who the [ __ ] i am no i don't
and i still don't know what the [ __ ] you
do well get it get with it google it
well you're a guy who has holes in his
hat dude
that's all i know about you yeah he
looks like a [ __ ] homeless man ethan
that's true i won't argue with that yeah
i'm not gonna argue with that yeah i'm
not gonna yeah anyway dude um i love you
i'll talk to you later okay [ __ ] off let
me talk to him just wrap it up you've
been through enough bobby just right
yeah yeah yeah this has been a tough one
yeah after what you put these beautiful
people there i mean beautiful person
yeah and
anyway bobby this guy's a freak i don't
even remember his name ethan i'm gonna
rap i wanna talk to him
ethan go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] you man i
[ __ ] hate that yeah yeah you're
bringing out a really bad side of me i
don't like to bring that side out and
not do it every time brings it up yeah
you've been an [ __ ] since you've been
here bro what when i can't [ __ ] don't
talk something like that no
i know you just calm down dude all right
i'm gonna type on now yeah we don't know
you got me all right
through the whole episode okay okay we
were having a nice conversation
you got super jealous and got super eggy
and the vibes just went
oh eggy huh what's your eggie you look
like a [ __ ] egg right
look at that right